[Music]  this is typical then or what you'll find  down here in the sewer sort of thing  that we find washed up clogging up thing  so these are wet wipes that's a wet wipe  yeah so people just anything that wet  wipes are a problem they just fussing  don't Euler yeah so I think people think  once if it goes through the u-bend on  your toilet and it's gone then it's out  of sight and very much out of mind and  we find all sorts down here so it's not  just wet wipes but sanitary products fat  it cotton buds condoms all sorts of  things but this isn't paper and this is  months old that would have been down  here for many months and as you can see  it's not disintegrated at all it's  because it's plastic it's plastic it's  not paper like you like your toilet roll  the only thing that should go down the  toilet is toilet paper poo and wee and  everything else should go in the bin